we're going to start with a very natural
real world problem and then I'm going to
explain to you a very different problem
in pure mathematics that surprisingly
solves this real world problem
you want to buy something on the
Internet so here's you
and here is this online store and
between you is this channel we all know
and love called the internet but the
internet is a little bit of a noisy
channel so say if you want to buy
something from this store you might want
to send the store 16 numbers your credit
card so like eight three five two
whatever nine one one five that's not
your credit card that's not my credit
card but you want to send 16 numbers
over the internet to this store or maybe
somebody else is sending 16 numbers and
say that your credit card number is
eight three five one
you really don't want the store to
receive your credit card number by
mistake instead of somebody else's
credit card and charge you so you want
to some way build in redundancy in the
way that you send these numbers so that
if there's an error you can first figure
out that there's an error don't charge
the wrong person and second of all maybe
correct that error you might
okay I've heard of this this is error
correction this is error correction I'm
going to explain to you one of the uh
first beautiful examples of an error
correcting code before we do beautiful
examples let's just say what is the most
naive thing you could do how could you
use redundancy to be able to detect when
errors occur any ideas
I would imagine I would imagine sending
it twice oh yeah send the numbers
multiple times so if I had this sequence
and I sent them multiple times I would
send eight eight three three five five
one one five five okay send each number
twice so now if one error occurs here I
say aha I was expecting each pair to be
equal and here's a pair that's not equal
so error and now I know but that doesn't
let me correct the error because I don't
know which was right two or one so of
course if I wanted to correct it send
each one three times
so if I send each one three times
um I'll be able to correct the errors
let me just write that down
888-333 I'm actually writing this down
for a reason uh
it's it's it's a lot more numbers right
so if this one becomes a one now I know
it should be a two because two was the
was the most common answer in that
triple but you'll see that this is two
times the amount of numbers or three
times the amount of numbers and nobody
wants to sit on their browser uh and
wait a long time to make a credit card
transaction because you had to send way
more numbers it's unwieldy so we want a
much more efficient way to build in
redundancy to solve this problem
okay I think I want a new sheet
well before I tell you a nice way to
solve this problem uh now we're going to
switch to a totally different problem in
pure mathematics imagine that you have a
collection of random points so you could
think about these points in the X Y
plate so each of these has an x
coordinate and a y coordinate when I
have this random collection of points
what I want to do with it is I want to
thread a curve
through
this collection of points and as you can
see what I did I really wanted my curve
to exactly pass through each one of
these points it's not something
statistical I actually wanted to pass
through each one of those points and
when I have one of these curves that
threads through the points I'll say that
this curve interpolates those points so
the main question that you want to
understand for interpolation is how
complicated does this interpolating
curve have to be so you might imagine
right if I have more and more random
points if I want a curve that has to
exactly pass through all those points
each time it has to hit a new point it
maybe has to twist a little bit or turn
or move so it has to get more
complicated as the number of points
grows I intuitively know what you mean
by complicated but is there a proper
definition of the complicated we're
getting there we're getting there so um
so exactly for that reason that I want
to quantify this I'm going to switch
this problem around and I'm going to
turn it on a Ted and I'm going to say
that I fix some type of curve and I know
this is still very abstract but we're
about to do examples so fix some type of
curve and once I fix this I fixed how
complicated this curve is already
and then what I ask is what is the
maximum number of random points it
interpolates so I've just flipped the
problem on its head fix the curve and
then say given how complicated that
curve is
does it have the flexibility to pass
through how many types of points
should we do some examples let's do the
first example let's suppose I gave you
two points so what's the least
complicated type of curve that you can
think of that interpolates two points a
straight line a straight line definitely
so yes a line always interpolates two
points but if I were to give you three
points and remember I want my points to
be random they probably won't lie on a
lie
so 2 is the maximum number of points
that a line interpolates
okay okay so now I thought alarm would I
thought a line actually covers an
infinite number of points but oh very
very good very good point it does cover
infinitely many points you can imagine I
can put some other points onto this line
but these are now not random and
remember then in our main problem we
very judiciously required them to be
random points one way you can think
about it is take the points that are on
the line and just imagine bumping them
all in random directions if I were to
bump these in random directions like
there would no longer be a line right it
would have to be some sort of twisty
curve that would interpolate all those
bumped points okay so that was two
points let's try to do more points next
example let's do three points okay any
idea for uh for the simplest type of
curve you can think of that interpolates
three points you can do it with a circle
so these are very classical results of
course Euclid new align interpolates two
points he also knew a circle
interpolates three points and Euclid
didn't have equations for these curves
or anything he only had things you could
synthetically construct so you can
actually construct the circle
interpolating three points it's not
going to look good if I freehand it uh
go on let's say yeah let's see your
skills nope that looked very elliptical
that is that's a terrible Circle I could
have done a much better job with this um
anyhow so this was these are these are
two very classical results that were
known to Euclid same thing three random
points if you have four random points
they won't lie on a circle okay so now I
want to describe to you another type of
curve but it's built out of polynomials
so it's built out of a polynomial f of x
let's suppose that we first have a
linear polynomial so a degree one
polynomial so let's say this polynomial
is like X plus two so when you see a
polynomial like this uh and maybe you
think back to school the first thing you
want to do is you want to start graphing
the values of this polynomial in the X Y
plane remember my points are in the X Y
plane let's see when I plug in 0 I get
two when I plug in 1 I get three when I
plug in 2 I get four you see where this
is going if I plug in any more values I
I always just get the straight line
right here and this curve that I am
making for you you is the graph of this
polynomial f of x I think I'd like
another sheet of paper I'm sorry I can't
write Smalls
now we're going to do a degree two
example so let's just choose some random
polynomial of degree two like um
x squared minus 4X plus 7. so again I'm
going to graph the the values of this
polynomial in the X Y plane all right so
if I plug in 0 I'll get 7 so that's one
point on the graph if I plug in 1 I'll
get 1 minus 4 it's minus 3 plus 7 is 4 4
if I plug in 2 I'll get 4 minus eight
plus seven I'll get three right and
let's do another one let's do four if I
plug in 4 I'll get 16 minus 16 plus 7 so
I just get 7 again so you can see this
graph it looks something
like this Parabola through those points
so in both of these two problems uh what
I was doing was I was starting with a
polynomial and then I was getting points
on a certain type of curve which is the
graph of a polynomial so I'm now going
to flip the problem around this way that
I've set up the interpolation problem we
fix the type of curve which is the graph
of a polynomial of a certain degree and
then we want to know how many General
points does it interpolate okay so this
linear case it's a line we already knew
how to solve a line it interpolates two
general points that means I can specify
two points on here
if I pick any two points I can always
find a linear polynomial so that the
graph of that polynomial interpolates
those two points and now this has a very
explicit description right because these
points are of the form some x value
comma f of x what you're trying to do is
you're trying to choose some inputs and
then find a polynomial that Maps those
to specific outputs
is it almost like saying what's the
minimum number of points I can have and
know the
know what my thing looks like it's very
related to that
um and I but I'm asking for a sort of
the maximum the amount of Freedom you
have the maximum number of points you
can have and still have it lie on such a
polynomial so here you could do two for
degree two any guesses for what it is
it's three
um it's sort of like how you went from a
line to a circle except a circle is not
a graph of a polynomial right because it
fails the vertical line test but it's
still three here so you can always do
three and in fact there's a general
result here this is called the LaGrange
interpolation theorem so if you're given
n distinct inputs X1 through xn then I
get to choose any outputs let's say I
want to send X1 to y1 all the way up
through xn to YN any outputs then there
is a unique polynomial f of x of degree
n minus 1 such that it accomplishes this
it sends X1 to y1 and all the way up
through xn to YF this is the thing
that's going to solve our problem from
the very beginning
here's our problem from the very
beginning so remember we're starting
with 16 numbers and I think I'd like to
not use specific numbers for these I'd
like to give them names think think of
them as variables so I'm going to call
them A1 A2 all the way up through a15
a16. so here's the key Insight that
allows us to make this error correcting
code and these codes are called read
Solomon codes so this was read and
Solomon's Insight is to encode these 16
numbers A1 A2 up through a 15 a16 as the
coefficients of a degree 15.
polynomial so I use these numbers to
make a polynomial f of x
equals A1 x to the 15 plus A2 x to the
14 plus plus a 15 x plus a16. cool okay
so same data nothing has changed I still
it's just the data of these 16 numbers
what does that curve look like exactly
that's what we have to do so let's let's
graph this curve so if we were to graph
this curve okay this is I've this is
totally uh I'm just gonna this will just
be a schematic but you imagine there's
some graph of this
f of x and what the LaGrange
interpolation theorem tells us is that
if I know just the value of this
polynomial at 16 different inputs so
like X1 I know it's value at some other
point X2 I know its value all the way
16 points on here
that uniquely determines the polynomial
for me it's the same data as knowing its
value at 16 different points
so if you're over here trying to send
this information online
if you want to send this it's exactly
equivalent to sending the values at 16
different points f of X1 through f of x
16. so let me come back to this LaGrange
interpolation theorem and let me fill it
in a little more this end here was
really the maximum so if the points X1
y1 through x n y n are random then this
n is actually the max you can't specify
any more values and still have it lie on
the graph of a degree n minus one
polynomial okay so let's use that fact
to start detecting and correcting errors
remember the the thing we have to do is
we have to build in redundancy and so we
don't have redundancy at the moment
where if we just keep track of the
values at um at 16 points so let's let's
take this and let's add a little more
redundancy let's send also the value at
just one more point
17th point
so we're going to add in one extra point
still no problem it'll be the same
degree 15 polynomial whose graph
interpolates these 17 points and notice
that these 17 points are not random
random 17 points would lie on no graph
of 100 degree 15 polynomial okay but now
the benefit is suppose that there's an
error in transmitting this point instead
of transmitting that value I transmit
some other value
now once that happens this graph goes
away I mean you it no longer
interpolates all of these points because
it doesn't lie on that graph and now if
you think about it what I have with this
collection not this one but the
erroneous one these are now 17 points
and the internet doesn't doesn't have it
out to get you okay it's not it's not
sending a specific really bad choice of
a point it's some random random error
happens in this noisy channel so these
are a random collection of 17 points
which means that probably there is no I
mean within all likelihood there is no
degree 15 polynomial that interpolates
these 17 points because 15 is more than
what you get by LaGrange
and so what we have is we have a way to
figure out if there was an error very
easy way to figure out that there was an
error
but we don't have a way to correct the
error because we have to know that this
point was the wrong point if we knew
that this was the wrong point we could
leave it out and find the curve through
the other ones but we don't know that so
well what do we do just send one more
piece of data
send its value at an 18th point
so let me add one more X here so we're
sending one more value if we send one
more value then we will know that this
is the Imposter point because the
remaining points will still be 17 points
that lie on the graph of a degree 15
polynomial which is unexpected
LaGrange says we should only be able to
do that with with 16 points
and so we can correct our error so if
you look at this over here this really
bad way of doing it you have to send two
times as many points but using uh read
Solomon codes
there's this idea you only have to send
one extra number or you have to send two
extra numbers which is way better than
two times the amount of numbers or three
times the amount of numbers so when I
send my credit card details my 16
numbers
it's I'm sending 16 numbers plus two
other numbers are those two other
numbers to first order that's the that's
the toy model of what happens yes all
right yeah but like they're not all
these graphs aren't being plotted by a
computer and and mapped and things like
that that's not actually happening oh no
um it's a it's a very straightforward
way to combine the data of the
coefficients and get the values or to
combine the data of the values and get
the coefficients very easy you don't
have to graph it the graphing is just
what's happening behind the scenes in
the mathematics and and let me say it
might not seem that impressive right to
16 numbers 2 times 16 is uh 32 or 48 and
those aren't that much bigger than 17 or
18. but this one or two was independent
of the number of numbers so like a
million well 2 million is much bigger
but a million and one is not so much
bigger
so here's a theorem that I proved with
my collaborator Eric Larson from last
year a curve of degree
D and genus
G
in R dimensions